every time that the nazis would meet our
guys would go in
and beat the [ __ ] out of these nazi
bastards our guys would go in with
baseball bats monkey wrenches brass
knuckles
stink bombs to throw into the place so
when they come running out
our guys were waiting there what good
did the mob do and what bad
instant justice you went to the powers
to be
because if you went through the system
the system did ship for you
somebody tried to rape the guy's sister
he goes to the bosses
bosses oh he'll take care of that now if
you went through the system with the
prosecution the lawyers it's an
expediency
what you can learn from an old gangster
you can never learn if you went to
harvard
princeton you have these geniuses that
go to the best universities
and they can't do [ __ ] what was the
ugliest question
two guys to kill and two guys to do the
burial why
so the two guys they killed never knew
where their body was can i tell you who
the biggest organized crimes in the
entire world who the government
[Music]
my guest today is a former gangster
author entrepreneur father and a grandpa
and he wrote a book called the
chronicles of the last
jewish gangster from meyer to myron
myron sugerman thank you for being a
guest on valuetainment okay
nice to be here and thank you very much
for having me yes so look i've
interviewed a lot of italian mobsters
gangsters attorneys
you know some gangsters from uk some
we've had a lot of
but never jewish mobs so if you don't
mind educating
myself on the audience on the history of
the jewish mob okay i'll be glad to so
the jewish mob basically starts
at the time of the large immigration
from east europe in the late
1880s 1890s and of course
poverty they come into the united states
they move into their cities
and they form the ghettos of the united
states
whether it's baltimore whether it's
boston new york brooklyn detroit chicago
cleveland
and um these uh
the original the original jewish
gangster was really um
it was brutal he was he was he was a
brute it was brutal
uh in fact um
there's a book that i read many many
years ago that said
25 of the prisoners
in the new york prison system were jews
what were the crimes
a lot of the crimes were violence what
year was this
probably at the turn of the 20th century
got it right and
um the name of the book was called the
rise and fall
of the jewish gangster a jewish mobster
or something like that
the interesting part about it uh patrick
was that
um you they were involved in
in all forms of of shakedowns violence
beatings murders and prostitution
time all right
um the majority of the of the prostitute
in in that time were jewish women
they'd come they couldn't find their
husbands and the pimps would be waiting
for them on the piers
majority of the prostitutes in the 20s
were jewish not 20s
late late uh 1990s
1890s 1890s 1900s got it okay
so it was really brutal crime now the
generation that comes up that was either
born in the united states or
had recently immigrated from europe
let's say for example meyer lansky benny
siegel
lefty bulk alter my father's world and
so forth
some of them were born here and some
were
born on the other side and came as young
kids all right
and i'm talking now post 1900
so these kids start as gangs and what
they want
it's controlled territory and
neighborhoods and so forth
and the control of the ghetto they had a
responsibility as well
and that was to protect the the ghetto
from the uh
being invaded and beat up by kids from
other ethnicities
and so the the um the pushcart vendors
and the
storekeepers they would depend on these
young kids
to defend the neighborhood the young
kids
were responsible to take care of the
fathers the
uncles their grandparents cousins and
everybody that
that was their responsibility the other
way around instead of parents it was the
kids
the kids the kids that took a very good
point
so um
someone there was a very
very well-known gangster from newark
it's amazing
if i'll say to people who's abner
longies willman
if you didn't come from jersey you never
heard of him
he was on an equal level with meyer
lansky benny siegel
all right and with um
uh lefke bullculture
and murder and cooperate and so forth
we'll get into that
so his name was longie and where the
name long he came from
is uh came from the when the old-timers
were being invaded by italians or irish
or
other ethnicities they would holler in
yiddish
rift for the longer call the long one
longer so from the name longer came the
name longi
abe long swollman and he
was six foot two good looking guy uh
waxed rich during the prohibition period
became known as the al capone of new
jersey
75 80 of the alcohol that came into
came in under his rule again this is
still in the 1890s now this now becomes
the time of the prohibition
those kids that were gangs evolved into
businessmen but we'll get
i just want to before we get to anybody
um
as they as the young kids by the 1920 at
the time
of prohibition because the law starts in
1920.
you have um
the old-timers one of them in particular
arnold rothstein arnold ross
was the brain now the brain was
allegedly the guy that
uh fixed the 1919 world series together
with a
an ex-jewish prize fighter by the name
of abe attel this is white sox against
the reds they call it the black stuff
or something like that right right it
was the chicago black sikes scandal
we're living in a day and age if i tell
people what i'm gonna tell you now
they're surprised but we had thousands
and thousands
of professional prize fighters and it
up until the middle of the 1930s
one-third of the champions of the world
were jewish
up until the 1930s
so so very different jewish reputation
then
than it is today completely night and
day completely feared respected money
makers racketeering the original mobs
and it almost seems like when you study
the history they
they they almost took in and they shared
their secrets and they trade secrets
with the italian and the irish
uh uh so we'll get we're gonna talk
about arnold rothstein
so arnold rothstein uh he came from
he didn't come from the ghetto he came
from a middle-class jewish family very
well respected
and he himself wanted to be an outlaw
um he's the one
that actually in fact is responsible for
the modern day
mod uh he he he was the original
um money guy for bootlegging in new york
it meets uh we need young kids to
protect our convoys so go to the gangs
in the in the ghettos
and if he spotted somebody with
potential leadership
like meyer lansky or like lucky luciano
he
schooled them and he showed them you're
going to make more money
with this than you're going to do with
this
stop being thugs now you got an
opportunity to make a lot of money
through prohibition
everybody wanted whiskey everybody
wanted alcohol
so he becomes the father of
modern of the modern mob
uh he got killed
uh because he um he refused he welts on
a on a card game
where he claimed that the game was fixed
they shot him
he died with the name of the police of a
shooter on his lips he
it was true tonight code he died
and now you had the new guys take over
the the the connection between the jews
and the italians
i was talking to this young fellow that
you have here today and i explained
the common interest was making money
lucky luciano
had the the brains to see that money
could be made with the jews
and mayor lansky understood we can make
money with the intents instead of
knocking our brains out with each other
let's do it the italians however
up until 1930 1931 they were controlled
by
two forces it was called the casta mario
wars
the wars between joe the boss maceria
and salvatore maranzano they fought
over the control of the young turks
young turks being lucky luciano frank
costello joe adonis
um and so
the competition was between those two
forces from the old black hand
they were xenophobic meaning that they
wouldn't
we're from sicily or from this part it's
just like
we don't want to even do business with
guys from calabria from
naples and business with jews
forget about it i got about it we don't
do business with jews
they were xenophobic can you give me an
idea for for us today okay so we're not
there at that time you know you you come
from
europe you said january 12th to 1938
okay so you you've been around the block
you have this the question i want to ask
you is the following so
you say jews and italians there was some
friction between the two
who would you compare that to today is
there a comparison to make that to today
yeah over the period
over the period of post-war uh
world war ii uh you had
competition and it's very interesting
good question
you had competition between um
cubans when they were the new boys on
the block post
castro post batista so when the cuban
mob came here
it was formed they called themselves la
cooperacion
they went toe-to-toe with the italians
over the number holes
and over the the numbers business in new
york
to the extent that they were burning
down each one's number holes
and then ultimately there was a
declaration that
he sat down there to sit together the
boss of the
cubans was named jose miguel jose miguel
batley
and he sat with fat tony and they worked
out a peace agreement
the albanians and the italians but it's
always the italians the russians
and the italians but ultimately the
italians
they have these they have the structure
and the power
whether it's puerto ricans whether it's
dominicans and so forth and so forth
during that time when lucky you know
there's a costello himself banned you
know
meyer they're sitting there and you know
uh rothstein's kind of giving them a
you know formula here's how you do it
here's how you make your money and don't
let the two blocks
in order to do that they had to kill joe
with the bosses they had to kill
so the first one they took out was joe
the boss bustery in coney island
one jew and three italians bugsy siegel
together with three italians
went did the hit before joe the boss
masalia could eat that pasta bazoola
bianca
he was they ruined his appetite they
killed him yeah
then they had to take care of salvatore
maranzano
in that particular case lucky luciano
and that's a good story he goes to meyer
lansky and he says to admire give me
four year guys
give me four jewels because salvatore
maranzano will never recognize four jews
coming in dressed as irs
agents all right so meyer lansky's using
four four jewels um
bugsy i think one of the guys from dutch
schultz's outfit i always said louie
rush from downtown
and the fourth guy was um
sam uh red levine
all right that was meyer lansky's
favorite shooter now my
sam uh read levine
with a strong reputation he was a bit of
a religious jew
yeah he wore keeper all right eight
kosher
and used to tell meyer lansky don't give
me an assignment on shabbat
unless it's absolutely necessary he
wouldn't kill anybody on saturday
unless it had to be taken care of so
after they killed those two guys emerges
1930 31 the the commission and the new
crime
the five families and so forth and so
forth that's where lucky luciano
really gets the respect of everybody
to bring the five so because in fact it
was joe the boss masariyah
that kidnapped salvatore
lacania
it takes him to his warehouses and
threatens him that if you don't come
with me
i'm gonna kill you and lucky luciano it
was named
salvatore lakani at the time as the
original name of
lucky luciano says no i'm not going with
you they
sliced them up left them for dead and
that's how we got the name lucky
he was lucky to survive that's when he
went to myron to benny
the bugsy and says guys
god bless you we'll never we'll never
we'll never succeed as long as we're
under the
limitations of the repression of these
old xenophobic
dinosaurs got to get rid of them said i
got rid of them
and that's where the jews and the
italians
had a good understanding and excellent
understanding
that we're going to cooperate and
cooperation means more money
all right because violence is no good
violence interferes that's why when i
was telling you the story between the
italians and the
and the and the cubans see this jose
miguel batley
was a hero at the bay of pigs
he was one of the commanding officers of
that unit 4863 or whatever that was
that was part of the invasion of bayer
pigs
he was a c.i.a guy so when he came back
to the united
states uh they were the deal was
negotiated
so that the money and medicine went to
cuba to release the guys that were
locked up the prisoners on the bay of
pigs
jose miguel comes back and forms what's
known as la cooperacion
the corporation all right and they start
getting aggressive
in terms of putting out the uh the
buying the number halls number holes
meaning the illegal lottery
right now my involvement my friendship
was with everybody
because i was the the um the founding
father of the gambling machine business
i brought back the slot machines
from the time that laguardia knocked
them out in 1941 eliminated meyer lansky
and frank costello
i in 1977 started to put out the first
slot machines again
um i was a pioneer
so people say to me where did you get
the idea where do you get the balls to
do something like this
well i used to go all over the world
i've been to 70 countries i speak every
language on the face of the earth and
i do business all over the world which i
learned from my father
my father was in the jukebox of vending
in cigarette machine business
going back prior to 1938.
his original partner was doc stature and
abe greene doc stature was the original
partner with that gentleman i mentioned
before longies willman
right by the way longies willman waxed
extremely rich
during the time of prohibition
and whack and he was one of the big
financiers of the hollywood movies
uh he had a love affair with gene harlow
he made a great success out of gene
hollow the uh
he is she was the the marilyn monroe of
her time
so um doc stancher
was the original partner of my father
and long as woman
they split it long he took the cigarette
machine business
and my father's was the jukebox business
and how did long he take the
we had murder incorporated
should be people just i'm sure a lot of
people are going to be watching this i
said i never knew
all of this stuff the jews were that
tough
we had as many shooters and maybe more
than the italians
we had so many guys that were prize
fighters another thing
in the 1930s all right this is a
fantastic story
and nobody knows about it with the rise
of nationalist socialist
ideology in germany they come to the
united states
we had a guy by the name of fritz kun
kuhn
all right he declares himself as the
hitler
of america and he starts to rally
um and
bring together um the recent immigrants
that came post world war one after the
defeat of the
kaiser wilhelm uh we had a tremendous
amount of germans that came
to the united states north new jersey
was originally
a large german population we had beer
gardens
the br they call themselves the brown
shirts all right
brown shirts the brown shirts brown
shirts all right and it was called the
bund
bundy which means the organization in
in german and they would start beating
up on jews
my father was part of an organization
called the minute men
the minute men were all under the
supervision all under the administration
of longies willman
and they formed an organization called
the minutemen
which in a minute's notice was just like
in the revolutionary war
you would have men available in a matter
of a minute to go fight the british
our guys went to fight the american nazi
party
there's a book called the the the nazis
in newark written
by a dear friend of mine warren grover
that
relates exactly every time that the
nazis would meet
our guys would go in and beat the [ __ ]
out of these nazi bastards all right
and this went on throughout the entire
1930s
mariolansky took on the nazis in
yorkville up on uh
first avenue and 86th street um
beat the [ __ ] out of him up there it
went on in
in in minneapolis in chicago
the fine beat the [ __ ] out of him what
does that mean what does beat the [ __ ]
out of my
guys would go in with with baseball bats
they'd go in with monkey wrenches with
brass knuckles stink bombs to throw into
the place so when they come running out
our guys were waiting there all right
rising anti-semitism today people say
oh my god you know but in that time
jews were responding to it the the mob
in minneapolis
dave berman um
herman pastor sam duran
wherever the the the silver shirts
another
anti-semitic organization would meet our
guys were there
to beat the [ __ ] out of them all right
in chicago
there was a very famous prize fighter
triple crown champion hero at
guadalcanal by the name of
barney ross very great american hero
at fort aquatic canal when he was in his
30s
um he was a hero at guadalcanal
in the time of the nazis uh
they beat up they fought the
anti-semites at the jew haters in
chicago
one of the guys that that fought
together with barney ross was jacob
rubenstein some people said
who the hell was jacob robinson so let
me make it easy for you
jack ruby as a son of a [ __ ] jack ruby
yeah he was he was a jewish hero all
right
a bit of a new crazy guy but uh he was a
jewish hero
jack ruby he fought together with with
all the jews to
defend against anti-semites how
different is
how different was the jewish community
in the 30s versus today
so when you're hearing it hey
anti-semites you know hey
you know who you guys are going out
there fighting beating the [ __ ] out of
everybody versus today
you hear the same message and criticism
how different are the communities
between those 80 years
well i think the the economics was so
much
different today for example um
the the the attacks on anti-semitism
today
in the united states are against
identifiable jews meaning
people that cover their heads black
suits
beards they're identifiable and they're
in
the inner cities they're sharing
geography
all right let's say whether it's
williamsburg whether it's brown heights
borough park and so forth and so forth
they're being attacked
the jews in the suburbs
haven't really felt it yet right because
nobody's going into the wealthy suburban
neighborhoods
and attacking jews there all right
there's the anti-semitism
hasn't spread to that point the question
you're asking me about
80 years ago is that we everybody was
sharing territory in those days
all right so whether you were
identifiable or not you knew that this
was a jewish neighborhood
and there was the the question of well
we're going to go in there
and we're going to attack jews all right
and so there was a need for that kind of
defense
uh going back to the names you mentioned
and by the way i want to i want you to
finish the story about yourself in 1977
when you said you were doing the slot
machines and that's kind of how you
brought it up you were a pioneer how big
did that get and what kind of money were
you making at the peak
it was so huge it was so gigantic
they should build a statue for me
because i made a lot of guys rich
all right zillions of guys
what we were doing was we were taking we
we
started with slot machines and evolved
into video poker machine
and that just broke everything open and
when the
technology changed and we had a bill
acceptor that you could put up
you could start putting ones fives tens
twenties
oh that's a big deal oh my god oh my god
you'd have to go collecting coins you
were collecting now bills
so we calculate that at a certain point
in history
with no fixed figures but between the
fellows that were manufacturing
supplying and
and they could have been 200 000
machines
throughout the entire city new york and
again people saw i never saw it over
how are you going to see it because if
you're living on park avenue you're not
going to see it
but if you were living in washington
heights you walked into
every bodega had slot machines in the
background
200 000. wow i figured 200 000
and figure each machine average
approximately 500 per week per machine
so take 200 000 machines and multiply it
by 500
now 50 went to the store owner and 50
went to the operator that business
flourished for years
but until it became too competitive as
it became super competitive
that's when the that's where the the um
conflicts began
so that's a hundred million a week 50
million went to the store 50 million you
mean to tell me you guys were doing 50 a
week
so that was between a million
endless number of operators i wasn't the
only operator
i was the the grandfather of it all
right
but everybody went into it italians
dominicans puerto ricans i got what
you're saying russians
israelis got it everybody so everybody
was kind of sharing that together the 50
a week that was coming in how much of
that 50 was going to you
at that time oh probably
maybe well i had new york i would say
um between sales operation
over a hundred thousand a week yeah so
you're making a hundred thousand a week
in the 80s
yeah and what's your life like that the
time i mean you're listen
even off camera i watch you you have
charisma you're charming
you're mad you got you can use the words
you're very well spoken so how was your
life like
so i'm a bit of a unique kind of a
character because
um
i never i i never went higher than in
terms of the
the kind of lifestyle you know country
club none of this
i'm i'm a street guy i'm a educated
street guy one of the most
educated in terms of everything jewish
history
world of events current and so forth and
so on so i pursued a lot of that as far
as
life concerns but you were not living a
lavish lifestyle
jewish girl from buenos aires whose
family was from poland
and
we would have if we were told to come
here today but patrick
is going to interview you she would she
would she'd run to the other side of
america
why why is that what what's issue she
don't want school she wants nothing she
didn't want to know this woman what's
your strong personality though very
strong
okay she worked in a slot machine
business in buenos aires as
the bookkeeper that's how i met her got
it got it so during this time when
you're making that kind of money did you
ever get caught did you do time did you
ever get in trouble or not i had three
state cases in three federal cases i was
a revolutionary every time they locked
me up i was back the next day opening
doing business got it i was just a
defiant sort of a guy
and um i did time i um the last case was
a federal case
i had a federal case in washington d.c
and he'll get a kick out of this one
the name of the judge was harold greene
harold greene was the guy that broke up
the att monopoly
and he had the iran contra affair he was
the judge in that wow
so he was my judge i get locked up with
an
old-time mob guy by the name of joe joe
the possum nezlein
all right for promoting slot machines
that
joe joey was probably a little bit
senile at the time
he introduced me to an undercover fbi
agent
and i'm going all over washington dc and
going to black locations come on bro
you put my machine in here so okay pop i
gonna argue with you you look like
you were the man as i'm now of course
i'm with the man that's
you're putting machines i'm gonna put
machines here put machines there
meantime this fbi age is all white
i got locked up all right harold greene
is the judge
and the prosecutor is a young jewish
woman
i'm being real kind about it she falls
in love with me
all right she's in enchanted with me
and she ain't going to screw me one way
she's going to screw me the other way
she says you're the mayor lansky of our
time
and you know what i'm going to prosecute
you
i'm going to get ba so
my my kid my cousin was my lawyer and he
says to me
we had a plea bargain there was no way i
was going to win this particular case
the
fbi had me under so
my kid cousin says to me get in touch
with your friend
simon wiesenthal the nazi hunter
so i contact dr wiesenthal and he says
i'm in trouble
he says what do you need i said need a
litter so no problem he writes a letter
to judge green
and he says this is the man that helps
me
pursue nazi war criminals in south
america
right he's my man it's in my book
the letter that wiesenthal writes to uh
the
judge green judge green turns out
that he is an escapee from nazi germany
he was a kennedy democratic party wow
interesting so he gets the letter from
from simon wiesenthal and
calls this girl i don't want to hurt her
feeling sir
her terrible reputation any worse than
it already is
and he says the lady he says um what am
i going to do with this letter she says
the letter's false
sorry it's counterfeit she said go prove
it
anyways to make a long story short she
runs back in
she spoke to somebody she said how do i
know what was simon wiesenthal judge
says get the hell out of here
you called him or he called you just no
i caught get out
get out that letter's authentic all
right
day of sentencing as we plea bargain
the door opens in the chambers of the
law
of the uh court and
uh there's a girl comes out and she's
smiling at me
my kid cousin says to me says cause you
know that girl over there she's smiling
it just listen cause
that's not unusual i get smiled at all
the time by young pretty good women
um anyways go in front of judge
and in my sentencing report
it says mr sugarman is a close
intimate associate of vincent jimmy blue
eyes
aloy my cute cousin says to me
because you really know jimmy blue eyes
so i never met the man in my life
he says but it says because i'm telling
you i never met jimmy blue eyes
all right so um
this prosecutor she says to judge green
she says
uh although judge green says by the mere
mention
of a few italian sounding names
the government has failed to convince mr
this courtroom that mr sugarman
is a member of organized crime anyways
he gives me five years probation
all right uh two weeks later i get a
phone call
billy cain it's memorial day weekend uh
1997. 1987.
meet me at the bay way diner in
elizabeth i meet him at the bayway diner
so that pretty little girl was my half
sister she's a judge she was judge
green's
billy kane worked he worked for the
gambino brothers on 18th avenue fixing
his slot machines
he liked me he says oh tell the sister
you tell judge green he's such a good
guy this myron
he teaches all the slot machine
operators
how to rig slot machine set at the
jackpots
so the jackpots never what never pay out
so anyways um
a few years later i'm in a a
gaslight uh restaurant
a chinese restaurant in miami in miami
miami beach it was the gallows chinese
girl from elizabeth new jersey christine
lee jonah place
and i'm wearing with all all the
old-timers
and so one of the people said you know
look at that
who's at the table there i don't know
but
you don't know what that that's jimmy
blue eyes jimmy blew on his boom
interesting now come out he knew your
father let's go over i'll introduce you
nah let him he's with a woman let him
enjoy his dinner
so about two more years later
a fellow very good guy robbie margot
this is my room meet me at the hilton
hotel
we're going to have lunch today with
jimmy blue eyes
so fine now he show is late
she doesn't robbie goes downstairs to
make a phone call from the phone booth
who walks in jimmy blue eisen run over
jimmy how are you
he said who the [ __ ] are you i said
jimmy what do you mean who are we
i'm your close intimate associate he
says to me are you [ __ ] drunk
i never met you in my life and then i
told the story about
how on the the sentencing report
it says that myron sugarman is a close
intimate associate of jimmy blue eyes
listen the government does what it's got
to do and we have to do what we got to
do and
that's life and you take it with a grain
of salt your experience who was dirtier
over the years the government or the
mobsters the gangsters
both who was more creative
gangsters
what you can learn from an old gangster
you can never learn if you went to
harvard
princeton pennsylvania university
wharton school of business and so forth
there was an old timer by the name of
jake mohawk from newark
bookmaker and he used to say you see
these guys over here
they didn't even graduate sixth grade
and they have the ability to sit down
right and negotiate a peace agreement
you have these geniuses that go to the
best universities
georgetown university go this one school
of diplomacy
and they can't do [ __ ] he says isn't it
amazing
these old-timers without any education
whatsoever
can sit down and come to an agreement
shake hands on it
and that handshake is worth more than
all the papers on the face of the earth
made by the greatest lawyers so from
that particular point of view
it's quite a story i mean i've been to
many many sit-downs and
of course it's very interesting i was
with a guy
my grandson that i called louise drake
that's the guy i was with
from paterson new jersey super
professional
super professional so when we used to
have a sit-down dispute over territories
and so forth and so forth
it was wonderful you could not have
a discussion until you had your bola
pasta
your bread your olive oil
your olives and then your wine
and then your espresso coffee and in the
process of that hour and a half before
you would start talking business
what would you talk about well we talk
about baseball you talk about broads you
talk about boxers you talk about prize
fighters
you would talk about nothing that we
were ready to talk about
now when the plates were cleaned and
waiters took away everything then starts
the procedures and then
it went like this gentlemen remember
we're not lawyers
right if it could be said in 10 words
don't use 11.
number two they put erasers on the back
of pencils
for the purpose of erasing a mistake
number three what can never be erased
is a lie do i make myself
clear gentlemen let the proceedings
begin
you brought the beef against this guy
you go first
and the these old-timers they knew how
they were great to watch them and to
negotiate back and forth and so forth
and so forth and
at the end everybody um
i had a major sit down two times and the
last time was with um
each time was with a fellow by the name
of jimmy brown
jimmy fayala that was the acting boss of
gambit of
gambino after john gotti went to jail
god
he was fabulous he was on the other side
he was uh
gambino i love that old man um
at the end i said something that's
struck a real positive chord with him
i told this guy anytime you need my
mechanics
you call me before you take them on your
own
jimmy fayala he says he turns to his guy
and he says
i like this [ __ ] jew all right he's a
smart
[ __ ] kid and then he turns to me so
what do you want kid what can i do for
you
i says well you know mr brownies don't
call me mr brown you call me jimmy
i said you're smoking some nice cigars
today he says you like come on
there you go kenny grabs a bunch of
cigars and he tells louis red
you're lucky you got this kid this kid
is good he's good
he's good because i wasn't greedy and i
understood the rules the regulations and
so forth
and you life is very fascinating in that
world
everything's you have to be super honest
there's an old song that was uh
uh what was the the uh the kid from
from minnesota jewish kid that zimmerman
uh i can't even
bob dylan had a song yeah what the words
were
if you're going to be out you're going
to live outside the law you better be
honest
and that's the rules as far as life is
concerned within that world
now is there treachery is there deceit
is there
breaking of honor and so forth yeah yeah
it's human
it's all part of the human process so
um when you ask the question
as far as the government is concerned
they get all the power
all the time all the power all the
strength all the witnesses and so forth
so that when a guy would go to trial
right he was dead he had a three percent
chance of winning it's 97 percent chance
that the government's going to win in a
trial so that's why the plea bargain
everybody play bargains
that's a casino that's a good odds on
your end the house wins
they got it all yeah they have it all
and if they don't have it
it's just like that like the sentence
report
yeah let's go back i got a few things i
want to cover with him we'll be you know
we'll wrap up here
shortly so going back to the most
powerful jewish cancers of all time so
if you ask the average person they're
going to say who meyer lansky is going
to come up
lebke's going to come up who made a lot
of money and
racketeering what he was doing but he
was a family man he rarely drank didn't
do drugs he was a guy that was a
you know pretty steady and you go hear
about ben siegel strong hit man tough
guy good looking
good with the ladies virginia hill kind
of you know uh uh
caused the fall for him who else would
you put on the list
of uh the most powerful jewish mobsters
of all time
and what did each of them have that was
unique uh
compared to their peers so there is no
jewish gangster
anymore so i i really i am the tail end
because in jewish a real jewish gangster
on that level they were also patriots
american patriots and jewish patriots
it wasn't just the question of money
marilansky for example
longies willman um they
fought the american nazi party they
cooperated with the united states
government
in operation underworld in world war ii
and they supplied weapons and arms to
hagena
and te argun they'll create the state of
israel
post world war ii uh pre-state
in palestine pre-state israel
that's the reason why i was involved
deeply with simon wiesel
wiesenthal um so that i could
do my share of um
let's say participation as far as jewish
uh
above and beyond so it wasn't just
a question that they were protecting the
neighborhood or protecting the jewish
community and so forth
it went beyond that there was a
tremendous amount of patriotism
that was not people are going to watch
this i was
oh kind of patriots and they were
gangsters they were this
there's a a talmudic wisdom that says
life is not either black and it's
neither white it's all shades of gray
and everything as far as life is
concerned there's no way that you're
going to have it
specifically black and specifically
white you're going to have it of all
different shades
that's the human existence you want
perfect truth
when we go off to heaven and you know
that's
that's perfect truth when you're when
you're dying your clothes out
great a lot of great um you know
uh i've spoken to uh sammy and we've had
them on and
we've done a lot of different things
together with uh our interviews
uh and now he's got his own channel he's
doing stuff michael francis
colada phil leonetti ralph natalie oscar
goodman a lot of these different
personalities
uh did you ever have any dealings
yourself with gotti
or sammy gravano yourself or something
sammy would remember me we
we met in a big big sit down
and um it was an italian restaurant i
think it was called the sicilian on
second april 19th
uh it was a funny pla funny it was
it was it was completely closed off that
day
like a it took me four cars they drivers
to
exchange cars so that by the time we got
to the place
uh everybody in the place was a gangster
right
and sammy the bull was the moderator
that day
and uh i was brought there because there
was going to be a major
um combination of the genovese and the
gambino family they're going to put
together
a slot machine operation 2000 machines
and i was
asked the question if i would be able to
organize and administrate it and i said
that the risk of sounding a modest i'm
the only one that could
do something like that louie red the
buttons are popping off his shirts
that's my man that's my man jimmy brown
says
i told you that kid is good so sammy the
bull i met him
on all of your interviews it's very
impressive all of them
all most of these all that i've watched
these guys are very candid they're very
very
honest about their feelings sentiments
and so forth and so forth
it's very very good they're good you're
good
you bring out the best of these guys as
far as honesty is concerned
i appreciate that what was the biggest
thing you noticed from sammy
uh when you said he was a moderator did
he use humor was he
was he did he have presence was it
intense was it calm what was his
approach when you saw him
low-key low-key low-key yeah okay there
was nothing
there was nothing ostentatious about the
man he just was strictly business
gentlemen we're here what's this with
slot machines who's this one guy this
issue of garbage issue over this issue
over that and so forth and so
so it was basically again you were
sitting at your table
you were genevieve's table and other
guys would be sitting at a gambino table
and
whatever the issue was ours was slot
machine so you get called to the table
and sammy was strictly a moderator
strictly was he was he a feared guy at
that time did people fear him
i was told by my by my driver
by louis red's driver that took me there
he says this guy's dynamite
that was the expression he used he says
this guy is
dynamite referring to sammy sammy's from
gambino he's not from genovese my guy
tells me that guy is dynamite
that's the only experience i had as far
as he's concerned i knew
all the the you had um ralph
and that and natalie you had uh tommy
leonetti
um and um
[Music]
what's his first name michael micah
francis
not okay
so the philadelphia crowd there was a
crew in jersey
in newark it was down neck newark
and the guy that was in charge was tony
bananas now they talked about him
killing angelo bruno so his name was
tony
bananas capenegro i knew everybody from
from newark because i'm from newark so i
knew
that whole crew uh i knew a zillion guys
or vice versa they knew me because
guys that heard about the gambling
machine business
they jumped on it so we had everybody
from every crew from every street corner
throughout the entire city of new york
suburbs and so forth and so forth it was
a huge
huge huge business that i created
and this is this is still in the 80s 77
on it went from 77
and then until i got locked up in 95.
i went to jail in 95. 95.
so that that's about that i think
natalie
did you have any dealings with joe
molina or no no
no my connection was with newark with
the philadelphia
azeroth brooms outfit and newark the guy
that killed him was
tony he was the capo regime he was the
guy that was in charge of newark and
never anything with scarfo
i met him one time just he was eaten in
their restaurant and
one of the kids from newark said to you
yeah i get to meet the
nikki scarf did you get the feeling from
like did you feel no i didn't have
anything
okay so you don't have any kind of
opinion about okay the guys that that
were extremely extremely close that i
was close with was
all the way upstairs on top jerry katina
from newark uh was my father's partner
in the jukebox when they visited
doc statue along these woman mayor
lansky those people i knew
those were your okay so how was meyer
when you met him what was meyer like
a gym a gentleman a gentleman and so
forth
but that time he had run away and met
him in israel
my father's partner doc stature what
year was this when you're making
this dean seventy seventy when he wanted
to get citizenship but they turned him
down and didn't give it to him is that
the time or
okay yeah yeah he went he he he knew he
was going to be indicted
he ran to israel my father's partner
original partner was joseph doc stature
doc stature
was uh he was a genius absolutely
what a what a mine but doc stature
accepted
exile from the united states and a deal
that he worked out with edward bennett
williams
the great lawyer from washington and
robert kennedy
he actually made the deal with kennedy
to accept
exile from the united states he was in
israel
he told me on one saturday afternoon or
saturday morning you'd be here for lunch
for shabbat and
just he never told me why and all of a
sudden maya lansky walked in
meyer lansky sat down next to me
i was a kid i was going to go to africa
the next
month to run slot machines for a
backdoor ballet deal
in lagos nigeria with a couple of arab
gangsters and they needed a manager
so um meyer lansky um
very polite very cordial and he tells me
listen
son he says they made me bigger than al
capone
that's why i'm here in israel because if
i go
to trial uh i'm gonna do life
and all it was was just a um
uh income tax case at the end of the
meal
he by the way says you know uh your
father was my very
very dear friend he was with us in the
riviera telling havana
he reminded me of my father same style
low-key
quiet gentleman they took me off to the
corner
and they were concerned at that
particular point about mr katina who was
my father's partner that bought
out doc stature after doc went to
went to l.a opened up the moulin rouge
and then he was at the
at the hotel flamingo and sands and so
forth and so forth
they were concerned about jerry katina
right
years it took me years later to figure
out all of the concerns it was all about
the rake off
who's in charge of the rake off because
once meyer lansky
left florida to go to israel who was in
charge of the
of the uh uh
the money if the coming into we used to
go to miami
meyer would have it packaged up and it
would be picked up by a fellow by name a
silva and fetterman
from geneva switzerland who was i think
somehow or another related to tibor
rosenbaum
who was the owner of a bank called the
international bank declared
which was the bank that banked both the
rake off
for the mob and was a mossad bank
it we worked it worked both for both uh
uh for both organizations
interesting now lansky's strength when
you
hear about lansky's strength you hear a
lot of different things you know the
whole
uh uh scene you see in the movie
mobsters with christian slater where
you know meyer wouldn't take you know he
would always fight back he didn't know
how to fight but he was feisty he was
willing to fight he was not afraid of
you
and then he's portrayed as a guy that's
very methodical very business
very strong but you know low-key didn't
need the attention he was a
what else would you say with some of his
strengths i mean i'm sure your dad told
you stories about meyer who
he probably had more dealings with so
mayor lance used to come to newark all
the time yeah
um and stayed at the old
riviera hotel it was a riviera hotel
actually on clinton avenue
and um he was he was just a low
low-key guy all right um
dress conservative thought conservative
and he was a patriotic american and a
patriotic jew
very strong on the question of jewish
identity
in terms of theology whether he believed
in god probably not
he didn't he wasn't a practicing jew
he was a nationalistic jew
all those guys participated in supply of
weapons and
arms at a time that the neutrality act
was invoked
by truman stating that it was a criminal
act to supply weapons and
arms to palestine either to the arabs or
to the jews
our guys played a significant role
in buying up weapons and arms
of um surplus weapons and arms post
world war
ii and we had all the shipping
connections at the port of new york
through frank costello and albert
anastasia
so that the longshoremen cooperated with
the jews with the zionists
to ship weapons and arms meyer lansky
and long east willman
played significant roles they went out
of their way
constantly so
the the value system of these people
uh meyer lansky would not be in the
dirty business
the dirty business being prostitution uh
or drugs
who was if he wasn't who was just about
everybody
really yeah it was it was so it was um
even his colleagues even even the
different families
yeah yeah and
my guy was louis streaky and he used to
say
every time every we we'd meet at a
delicatessen called carpenter and
passaic
it'd be a round table and everybody was
at the table and his message is
gentlemen we're not
in that business all right gentlemen
we're not not business and gentlemen
we're not in that business
i think everybody at the table was at
that business except myself
got it in some form or another if
patrick comes to me and says i'm not
saying patrick i'm saying let's say
mr mr mr john smith comes to me says to
me
finance me give me 25 000. right don't
ask any questions
you'll you'll have back uh 50 on your
money in
30 days all right please don't ask me
who
what when where how so everybody
got it in some form or another was
connected to that business
who trusted who like who how much of a
role did trust play or how much of a
role did
uh intuition play like what you know the
main gangsters who are sitting there
some sometimes saying i know this guy's
full of [ __ ] he's lying to me to my face
but i still have to figure out a way to
do business with them what mattered more
trust intuition street smart
how would you conversation of all
factors okay a combination of all
factors
um um
you all your interviews your guys tell
you trust nobody
every that was a common thread through
all your interviews with
the fellas that we mentioned before it's
very difficult to trust in that world
somebody says what is the definition of
the word friend
all right friend is a sacred word we've
got two guys i'm going to take this
bottle of water and take this bottle of
water
i'm one guy and my best friend is
this guy all right we get nailed
we get brought down to police
headquarters all right
they put me in one room and they put my
best friend in another room
and then they say to me sugarman
that guy over there uh moisha moishe's
your best friend i said he's a great guy
well that great guy is talking he's got
diarrhea of the mouth he's burying you
so you know what you better be a smart
guy you better bury him before he buries
you
and if i'm smart i'll say to him
gentlemen
kiss me which in translated yiddish
means
kiss my ass and if my friend maisha is
really my friend
he says kisme right
that's the definition of friendship all
the rest is
all [ __ ] guys huh kiss
embrace gonna have espresso coffee we're
gonna have a drink together and so forth
and so forth
and then what happens when the your your
best friend says to you
come on we're gonna take a ride tonight
we're gonna see somebody all right
and he's walking you right into your
death
michael francis it tells that story how
scared he was to go
anywheres and so forth he knows a very
smart guy
very very very talented very interesting
very very interesting and he tells
exactly the way it is
so uh the other factor that you didn't
mention you mentioned
intuition you mentioned smarts and trust
and all that
providence elaborate
providence god sometimes in life
we don't know where it's coming from all
right
it's saved because i had a
an attempt on my life one time two times
the first and second time uh was
by providence but my guy that
by supposed to meet in the morning who
never was on time
that particular morning was on time and
he spotted two guys
that were dressed in uniform long coats
caps and sure enough the guy shot up the
stairs
and uh
the truth of the matter was why was he
there that particular morning
364 days a year never on time
this particular day he was there on time
and was
stu and experienced enough to say those
two guys
they're here today they're here to do
you more than just harm
providence so trust intuition
um street and on top of that
providence um you know in the
in the in the mob world when you think
about the jewish mob you think about you
know
the italian mob what good did the mob do
and what bad did the mother obviously
when you think about the bad we know a
lot of the bad we read a lot about the
bad
but you know there's those that also
will say it did some good what would you
say the good it did to the uh
to the community um well on the
on the the local level uh if you
look at uh
somebody tried to rape my sister
as an example thank god it didn't happen
but let's say for example my my father i
can't even get to tell you how many
times
sugai was called in the middle of night
sugar can i come see i got a problem
uh such and such the union is that and
so forth this autism
my father was with jerry cadina so next
day ah
my aunt has a good story my aunt shirley
my mother's sister
she becomes a widow and she's got a
supermarket up in bound brook new jersey
a couple of tough guys come in bully her
and
mrs goldberg you're gonna do this that
she got scared she called my mother
mother calls me my father was already
passed away and she says
take care of that all right so i go to
see
abe greene i've sat there he said
telling to land surely to come comes to
the office
and she tells him the problem that he
got bullied and starting their union
episode
ape says what nice seeing you shirley
take care of yourself sweetheart
and surely says to me no what is
what's going on here he says go home
let me go home i came here to get the
thing and shirley
go home sure enough the next morning
she couldn't walk into a supermarket it
looked like a flower shop
there were bouquets and all of a sudden
you know
baskets of fruit and this that and so
forth and two guys show up with the hats
and
mrs goldberg we never knew who you were
we apologized and if you ever need
anything you come to see us and so forth
and stuff
that's a million times that story
of you went to the powers to be because
if you
went through the system the system did
shift for you
somebody tried to rape the guy's sister
all right
he goes to the bosses bosses so he'll
take care of that and sure enough
you know in the old days that guy that
was an attempted rapist he
never see him again all right
it was taken care of now if you went
through the system and they
were the prosecution the lawyers and
this and so it said expediency
you get justice instant justice
providing of course
and they bring that out in the movie the
godfather which is very accurate
to show that you get expediency as far
as
the justice is concerned whereas if you
go
to civil cases i said you a sewer guy
all right
guys screwed you for money you're going
to go sue them how many years is it
going to take before
never do you lose the case two to four
years
with luck you get two to four years yeah
all right you're unlucky it might be uh
10 years waiting for
a resolution because it's going through
the system
so this so you asked an excellent
question
the benefit of of the mob is that it
cuts through all the [ __ ] gets right
down to the basics
what's the ugly what's the ugly i mean
i've read i've seen i've interviewed
i've
i've done a lot of research on that what
was the ugliest part
can i tell you who the biggest organized
crime is in the entire world who the
government
every government is the worst organized
criminal
enterprise on the face you know these
guys here they're midgets compared to
the government
except that the government look it the
government made me
oh he's the boss of the slot machine
business all right
uh sugarman he's the boss of the slot
machine business good
terrible thing go to my god he's
organized climate
he plays his slot machines you you
you're funny you're
funding organized crime okay good uh
turn on your television set and you
watch on television
all right guys playing in their living
room
on a computer the same slot machines
that myron sugarman operated in bodegas
20 years ago all right but now you can
sit in your living room and you can go
broke
play in the same slot machines that my
machine but this is good because there's
this government and then we're going to
have taxes and the taxes are going to be
good
it's going to help people and so forth
and so atlantic city
is still a [ __ ] house after all those
years from 1978
that all that money that's going to be
used for the benefit of blah blah blah
it's all [ __ ] government is your
biggest
criminal organization on the face of the
earth but
it's a necessary evil all right
many years ago my father's partner and i
explained to you that
brought out dark statue become the
acting boss of the genovese crime family
jerry katina underrated
understated the most brilliant man
one of the most brilliant men i ever met
in my life
a desk like this he would be sitting
reading the manchester guardian the
christian science monitor wall street
journal
and new york times self-educated man
my father used to say
mr katina he could run the pentagon
or general electric and with the passing
of years
i come to the conclusion that man could
have been the president of the united
states of america
he had such a skill and administrating
of people
talent and intuition and instinct the
genius about himself
all right at that party in 1991
september 13th 1991 i met how many
archie's
home in fort lauderdale in uh florida
for his wife's 70th birthday very
different of my fathers and mothers
and he tells me the old man wants you to
be at the party tonight
and i'm honored and of course when mr
katina walks in everybody was like oh
jerry
good to see you he says to me get over
here sit down
and then he of course he's super
comfortable with me because he can talk
to me
like he can talk to nobody else
and then he says to me i was just
another chief operating officer
of just another corporation
and i never forgot those words right
i was just another chief operating
officer makes sense
of course it made sense i kept peace
resolved problems labor unions
recruiting everything
made everything work made it all work so
it's so interesting when you
other which which one of the five
families was the best
ran tightly ran money making
feared which of the five was that well
at different intervals
it depends upon the leadership for
example mr katina
my goodness gracious that man he could
have easily been the president of the
united states of america
the ballet deal okay valley
manufacturing valley slot machine valley
um hotels and so forth okay okay
my my father's company runyon sales
company
was the official distributor for ballet
manufacturing company
before the slot machine business they
made slots before
the war but my father's company becomes
the distributors for ballet in 1946
uh and they made a machine called the
ballet bingo
it was a subterfuge gambling device
looked like a pinball machine
it was a phenomenal machine bali bing
dingle baller bingo a belly bingo
pinball that machine looked like it had
a hand that came out of the machine
and grabbed the money out of your pocket
interesting it was a d
it was the most seductive piece of
equipment on the face of the huh
all right and robert kennedy knocks it
out in 1992
all right he says that machine is the
same thing as a slot machine
and he makes it uh amends what was known
as the johnson act
passes a law called the eastern act 19
1963 stating that a valley bingo machine
multiple coins
pinball machine is a gambling device and
cannot be
shipped interstate and knox bali out of
the box
valley goes into foreclosure the manager
of that company was bill o'donnell
the original owner was ray maloney
brilliant man
and the new manager or the manager that
ran the company
was bill o'donnell the maloney family
was no longer involved with the business
they come up with a hopper somebody but
it invents
a hopper system that takes a slot
machine from a mechanical device
that only pays out 20 coins and it's
going to put in a hopper system
that's going to spit out hundreds of
coins thousands of coins
in fact it's going to spit out
eventually dollars and something like it
bill o'donnell calls my father says sugi
could you introduce me to bill o'donnell
says sure goes to uh go
could you introduce i'm sorry could you
introduce me to jerry kathina
my father says to jerry katina bill
o'donnell from bali you never met him he
wants to talk
he's got a proposition he said don't
make him out comes
and he sits in the office in springfield
new jersey in a matter of two and a half
three hours
jerry katina hammers a deal where they
take the company out of foreclosure
all right and goes on to be ballet
manufacturing company
jericho did the machine was so great all
right
jerry catina understood in a matter of
seconds
that this was going to revolutionize the
slot machine business
he caused the people from enterprise in
buffalo which was
a jewish family that owned all the
baseball
concessions and so forth he gets money
from them he calls sam klein in
cleveland ohio big cigarette machine
operator he's a smart businessman
he had that kind of connection that he
could call people around the country
and hammer a deal together took two
hours to hammer the deal get the money
up take the cup take the factory out of
foreclosure
and become ballet manufacturing company
then he calls up his friend
dino dean martin in vegas and he says
the day he says
i'm sending you abe green
introduce them to all the hotel owners
and that's how value machines get tested
and in a matter of they own 95
of the slot machine business in las
vegas nevada
for years and years and years and years
mm-hmm
so when you talk to me about who was
this who was which
which crew jerry katina
was was was a phenomenal now you had
some guys that were just
paul castellano really
well sammy the bull told you the man
should not have been
a mob boss he distanced himself
he was too legitimate he was making
money too legitimately
and he didn't have that human touch the
guy that should have been
was o'neill it should have been
according to sammy the bull and john
gotti
was the guy that really should have been
but again um
carlo gambino was genius
from what i what i was told as far as
the streets are concerned
you have to have leadership quality to
be a boss to be a mob boy did you ever
do anything with sunny francie's or no
no nothing was sunny no and and uh did
you ever think that
uh sammy uh uh could have one day been a
boss or no you saw sammy as
underboss to gotti and that was the
relationship they had i don't think i
had enough experience with him in order
to make that joke okay
if i judged everybody against jerry
katina
nobody was qualified jerry katina you
put him at the top
so jerry's your goal jerry's the
greatest boss you've ever
he was a it was a superb okay superb
discipline
we called him an a an iron fist and a
silk club was he more a mobster an
earner a leader what was he everything
no he was no mobster so he wasn't the
one that was going out taking people out
and but maybe in his youth for sure okay
nobody nobody fooled them
but i used to see manchester guardian
christian science monitor and so forth
yeah
self-educated man tremendous context
throughout the entire united states
he rose up the ladder as far as success
was concerned
sue tai and acted accordingly
all right a gentleman
there was no such thing as um you
couldn't
a legitimate if you had a legitimate
need you were a good guy
you went to him for a favor i threw
through the ranks you got the favor done
again i'm going to ask you one question
i'm curious enough if you have any other
kind of version of story to this john f
kennedy
assassination i've heard hey now i've
interviewed 20 people on the topic of
john f k
you know jfk assassination what do you
know the involvement of ruby the mob
the cia lbj what do you know so so
jimmy blue eyes tells me the story okay
i used to meet with him once a month
downstairs in the hilton hotel so i said
to him one time i said jimmy
this kid harvey oscar
he says we have better [ __ ] shooters
than lee harvey oswald
it's all [ __ ] we had nothing to do
with him
i says but tell me the story
he says okay joe kennedy
all right joking the nicest thing you
could have said about joe kennedy
is that he hated italians more than he
had to jews couldn't stand italians
could he couldn't stand jews so
um he wanted jack kennedy to become
president right he reaches out to peter
lawford
his uh son-in-law you were friendly with
that
little skinny guinea frank sinatra
we need a favor what's the favor you go
to him
you're part of the rat pack tell them we
need
cook county chicago we need west
virginia unions
in order to get uh kennedy elected
um chicago
um dewey no no no dewey was new york
the prosecutor no the irish daily
daily richard daley uh irish catholic
uh democrat uh sam mooney
all right they get together we're gonna
get this guy elected all right
now um he gets elected
all right here's the here's the
mentality
you came to me for a favor your man got
elected
it was me that got him elected
our guy got him elected hello
oh we got a claim on you
you owe us big time
joe kennedy says what's happening
he said well these italians are by the
way you [ __ ] with these italians
you got a girlfriend by the name of
judith extra campbell
she's between you and sam moody you're
sharing a girlfriend
you're sending messages to him he's
sending messages to you
quit that [ __ ] where's your brother
robert come here
come here bobby you're going to be
the united states attorney general all
right because you're mean and vicious
like the old man
your brother jack all he wants to do is
screw everybody
all right so you're going to get rid of
these italians
because they are a pain in the ass
they're a pain of my irish
ass okay
he opens up the crime uh uh
passes a bill called the omnibus which
is the
preface to the eventual local the uh
um uh rico
all right he has a department within the
state
within the united states department of
and auntie justice and all right it
starts with robert kennedy
now in the mind of the italians they say
wait a minute
wait what are you doing here we got you
elected now you're going to go after us
you
son of a [ __ ] kennedy bastards
i told you you never could trust an
irishman
that irish son of a [ __ ] and so forth
and so forth now
i used to go to dallas texas at the back
pinball machines
from an old friend of my dad by the name
of abe sussman oh
and he was abe was the connection jew in
in dallas
so dallas always answered to chicago
chicago everybody that crew in dallas
and well everything west
of uh up until vegas vegas was over jax
of chicago jackson
make sense yeah yeah so if some jew
from chicago got himself jammed up in
dallas they used to call
abe and say hey we got one of your jews
here got it get him on an airplane get
him that lady yeah
all right that was the system
in dallas texas and that explains
how jack rubinstein jack ruby
was in the dallas police department
because he used to buy coffee hang
around he was low
level but he was a low-level jewish
gangster from chicago
all right now that it raises the whole
question
what the hell was jack ruby doing in the
dallas police department
and killing lee harvey oswald
sorry where it concerns
legends and myths all right we'll sit
here from now
until the cows come home because the
same stories over and over who killed
loggies willman
who killed this one who killed that one
and so forth who killed marilyn monroe
if you weren't there if you weren't
involved in a hate you don't know
by the way carlo gambino was very smart
he used to send two guys to kill
and two guys to do the burial
why so the two guys that killed never
knew where their body was
yeah so the two guys who killed never
knew where the body was
right here you i'm gonna send you to do
the killing
and i'm going to send him over here to
do the bury so that you can never say
i i'll take you where the where the
where the body is
so you killed you brought the body to
him he took the body and buried it yeah
so you don't he knows you killed him but
you don't know you don't know that
he don't know he's you go to such and
such a destination
pick up a body and bury it okay
but he doesn't know who killed them of
course not hey
why was that what was he doing that is
it too because you know without without
knowledge of the body
there's nothing there's no there's no
crime no body no crime so meaning no one
really knows what happened i mean
there's all these stories so that was
exactly exactly it's all speculation
but abe sussman the old friend of my
dance
told me that jack ruby was just a knock
around guy that ran a few strip clubs in
dallas texas
right but he was close enough
in the police to what police department
has a
schmegetti like uh jack ruby
hanging in this place with a pistol
so that that oh of course added fuel to
the any
any unique story you heard about hoffa
again i've heard
i've heard many of them is there any
unique story you have on hoffa
um too many stories so
the movie who killed them meaning who
killed alpha
no no but i i
i did go to see a hit man by the maheshi
ko koningsberg harold kale comes but he
was up in attica
he was in his 50 he was in his 46th year
when i went up to see him
right and i asked him i said because he
was a known killer
stone cold killer um
did you you have anything to do with the
uh
offer often none of your
[ __ ] business is okay i'm sorry heshi
he says but i will tell you something he
says
i'm the guy that was involved in
supplying weapons and arms
to uh israel and i'm here with a
journalist by name
an award-winning journalist my name is
david samuels all right this is cute
story
so uh hes she said 46 years
he says to me um
i'm the guy that told me mushy diane
mushy diana i said muchy we're on a boat
in
um marseille and might say france
all right and there's going to be guns
and weapons i'm going to just give
this to haganah i'm going to give this
to ergon
and i'm giving this to the stern gang
all right and if you say
one [ __ ] word i'm going gonna blow
your balls off do you understand
and he says years later 1940 and 1950s
he says years later
this was this was 1940
and he says in 19
it was in 1947 what the hell was it oh
in 1947 48
he says i run into jabotinsky the father
of the revision of zionist movement
and he pinches me on my chin and he
tells me
good [ __ ] job good job harold good
job
terrific and i said to david uh
samuels don't you say your [ __ ] word
john butzinski died in 1970
so guys would put themselves in
situations
that i was here i was there i was this i
was that and so forth and so but
too many stories so maybe michael is
right when you said he can't trust
anyone in that world
he was brilliant yeah michael michael's
interview
genius michael michael is uh
he may be one of the best communicators
in the marketplace
he's very very in his own way yeah very
unique well listen
i really enjoyed i'm so glad you made it
out here and i know you know the the
occasion it kind of worked out for
everybody
we have a legendary person here with us
as well streaky
that's sitting to my right to your left
and my grandson yes but i
really enjoyed talking to appreciate you
for coming out folks if you're watching
this
we're going to put the link below we're
going to put the link below to
myron's book the chronicles of the last
jewish gangster from meyer to myron the
link will be below
uh to order on amazon and with that
being said thanks for coming out
appreciate you once again thank you very
much
it was nice it was nice and i watched
all your
videos and i got that phone call the
other day i said to myself
wow i'm going to be a superstar i'm
going to have trophies
i'm going to have women who are going to
women who want to take selfies with me
oh my goodness you're no longer going to
need tinder just because of
valuetainment
i'm going to have to walk around with
bigger than my cage not going to no more
swipe rights i
completely different story and angle
about what he had to say about the
history of jewish mob how powerful they
were before
25 of inmates very interesting history
of the jewish mob
that myron shared with us if you enjoyed
this interview i'm curious to know your
thoughts comment below
put a thumbs up subscribe to the channel
and last but not least two other
interviews i want you to watch
one is with samuel garvano we talked
about sammy a lot and the other one is
phil leonetti he did an interview with
me and he asked for the camera to be off
when i was
not you know for to not show his face
it's a very interesting interview with
phil leonetti
the former underboss of the philadelphia
crime family click over here to watch
that take care everybody bye-bye